lake mead is at its lowest level it has
ever been today standing at
1095.9 feet and that is the source of
course of our water but did you know
that a decision nearly a century ago
affects how much water nevada gets the
i-team's vanessa murphy live in studio
to explain brian and denise in 1922
seven states including nevada signed on
to the colorado river compact back then
nevada's population was estimated at 81
000 today it's more than 3 million
now southern nevada was allotted 300 000
acre feet of water it was the smallest
slice of the colorado river
approximately 40 million people rely on
the colorado river for water 5 of them
or 2 million are in nevada but the state
gets only 1.8 percent of the river's
water how did this happen in 1922 nevada
signed on to the colorado river compact
it divided the river between the upper
and lower basin part of arizona colorado
new mexico utah and wyoming and the rest
of arizona california nevada and new
mexico based on that agreement more than
20 years later those states divvied up
how much water they'd get between them
nevada getting the least while more than
half of the water goes to two states
california and colorado there really
wasn't any expectation that we would
have the community here today at that
time bronson mack is the outreach
manager for the southern nevada water
authority so the colorado river really
was divided up based on agriculture as
far as moving forward for those
allocations it's really a matter of the
seven states developing new agreements
that provide flexibility in how we use
water how we share water on the river a
federal water shortage was declared in
august in a 60 minutes interview which
aired in october colorado state
university climate scientist brad udall
said laws governing the colorado river
need to be revisited in some ways a
little microcosm right in this whole law
of the river with these systems that
have been put in place that just don't
work they can't work and that's why a
rethinks needed
[Music]
reality check they're big fines if you
don't change a watering cloth in the
meantime the southern nevada water
authority is urging residents to
conserve water as lake mead levels are
at a record low if the colorado river
was divvied up
or reapportioned that would ultimately
mean that some states would lose water
some states may gain water and
ultimately the expectation is is that
would land in decades of litigation
one question viewers have been reaching
out to us with why do we continue to
build in the valley if there's such a
critical water shortage i asked bronson
mack about this he points out people
keep relocating here and of course they
need housing and also new builds are
required to have water smart landscape
and water used inside homes gets treated
and reused by the way we have a list of
the top water users in the las vegas
valley at 8newsnow.com
under the i-team tab back to you